[Music]
all of you that's really her I was the
original emoji meet smiler there is
nothing like cutting skin for the first
time she's more than a pretty face I
will never ever make a mistake again we
know you know the first time you said it
it's not a genuine but then you repeated
it and that was weird all right good
talk the emoji movie
[Music]
what sending an emoji okay be cool
welcome to the secret world inside your
phone
we're emojis like me work and live here
each of us does one thing and we have to
nail it every time incoming tax we are
go for met me
[Music]
or is that I've got to get this phone
fixed this has never happened before
and now alex has made an appointment to
wipe out his phone it's silly you're not
gonna run away from this I made a
mistake but I'm gonna fix it I think we
can make things right you just have to
go to a place where no emoji has gone
before the cloud I know a shortcut
there's math but no one's ever left our
city I know softer
[Music]
what is this place the greatest place
ever I've never eaten another piece of
candy again
high five don't do it don't you do it
it's already been in there once we need
to get the master password access denied
this might take a while what access
tonight we're gonna have some dance our
way out everybody could dance
[Music]